the busiest border crossing between the
u.s and canada is open once again after
canadian police moved out trucks and
protesters who had blocked the
ambassador bridge between detroit and
windsor ontario
that protest part of a larger protest
against covert restrictions our chris
vancleave is there at the border chris
good morning
this morning the ambassador bridge is
back open to traffic and trade
after police broke the canadian border
blockade sunday arresting dozens of
demonstrators and towing vehicles ending
a week of protest over the country's
pandemic restrictions
sunday's police sweep came after a court
issued deadline to clear the road friday
night was there a safety concern
yesterday because it sort of felt like
you had a
24 hour staring contest with the
protesters
i certainly wouldn't call it a staring
contest but
it was communication and dialogue
between the police and the protesters
involved sarah groves says she's been
protesting against covet 19 mandates for
a year we felt that no matter what we do
these mandates are not going to end and
that's what this is about i'm tired of a
lockdown ralph paul frack voiced his
frustration at the protesters i love the
protest but i think it's gotten too long
to the point where a lot of people are
losing their jobs
the ambassador bridge is back open
traffic moving in both directions that
is welcome news for the auto business
they faced shutdowns in several states
and a financial impact estimated around
850 million dollars analysts tell us it
could take the supply chain months to
catch back up
michelle all right chris thank you very
much